dismissive discriminatory unsympathetic
towards its residents words used to
describe Rochdale Borough wide housing a
landlord that has and continues to fail
many tenants
after being put on notice last year
today the housing Ombudsman released a
damning report revealing troubling
details about rbh and the service it
provides what we found was common areas
of service failure and repeated points
of failure which is really concerning
and some of which relate to kind of
cultural attitudes frankly around issues
like damper mold some attitudes towards
some members of society some of their
residents which are frankly uh
disgusting attitudes which which
shouldn't shouldn't really exist in a
21st century social housing sector it
was the tragic but preventable death of
a wabashak a two-year-old boy who was
exposed to severe damp and mold that
highlighted worrying concerns about rbh
despite his family's repeated calls for
help they received none
his death was labeled as a defining
moment within social housing in Britain
but not much has changed
the bed is well is getting more the wall
all around for six years the three
bedrooms in Richard's flat have been
riddled with mold he's scared for the
health of his one-year-old son and his
elderly parents his complaints to rbh
led him to being blamed this annoys me
you know he's made me angry because I
cannot do anything else I try to ask her
but
is
not happened
they were saying is about the cooking is
about to drying the clothes
is about to breathing is getting the
moisture because we're breathing in
night time
and we know getting fresh air into the
property but every day the windows open
we shared Richard's details with the
boss of rbh who assured us they'd
receive help for Yvonne Aerosmith
addressing homes with mold and damp is
her top priority it's why she fully
accepts the report's findings we are
really sorry to any residents that have
not been treated with respect
and that haven't felt that their voice
has been heard because that's just not
acceptable you know we do have a
significant problem we've done for mold
in in our properties and
we're getting all of those coming in and
trying to get all of the treatments done
as quickly as we can but it's a big task
and it's going to take us time to work
our way through that
a change of culture within the
organization which the Ombudsman said is
needed will also take time it's hope
these findings will act as a wake-up
call not just for this landlord but for
the struggling housing sector as a whole
intiman Rashid Sky News Rochdale